witaj z powrotem w kursie o rozumieniu kwantowej informacji i obliczeń, nazywam się John Watrous i jestem dyrektorem technicznym ds. edukacji w IBM
Quantum. To jest 10. lekcja serii i druga lekcja w trzeciej jednostce, która dotyczy ogólnego
sformułowania informacji kwantowej. Ta lekcja dotyczy kanałów, które reprezentują zmiany w
układach przechowujących informację kwantową. Obejmuje to użyteczne operacje, takie jak te wykonywane przez
unitarne gate'y i kwantowe circuit'y, jak również zmiany, których wolelibyśmy unikać, jak szum. Możemy też opisywać pomiary
jako kanały i tym zajmiemy się w następnej lekcji. Termin kanał pochodzi do nas z
teorii informacji, która między innymi bada zdolność przenoszenia informacji przez zaszumione kanały komunikacyjne
Kiedy więc myślimy o kanałach, myślimy abstrakcyjnie o kanałach komunikacyjnych.
Może się wydawać nieco dziwne, że skomplikowane obliczenie traktujemy jako kanał komunikacyjny, ale potrzebujemy
słowa, które odnosi się do ogólnego pojęcia procesu zmieniającego informację w pewien sposób i na dobre czy złe to słowo
kanał przyjęło się, niewątpliwie w dużej mierze ze względu na ogromny wpływ, jaki teoria informacji, a w szczególności
praca Claude'a Shannona w latach 40. XX wieku, wywarła na kwantową informację i obliczenia. Oto przegląd
lekcji: zaczniemy od podstaw, w tym definicji kanału, a także tego, jak operacje unitarne w uproszczonym sformułowaniu
informacji kwantowej można opisać jako kanały. Omówimy też fakt, że wypukłe kombinacje kanałów są kanałami i jeśli zastanawiasz się,
dlaczego to pojęcie wypukłości stale się pojawia, to dlatego, że jest to naprawdę fundamentalnie ważne pojęcie matematyczne w teorii
informacji kwantowej. Zobaczymy też kilka przykładów kanałów, w szczególności kanały qubitowe, które będą się pojawiać
co jakiś czas przez resztę lekcji. W drugiej części lekcji omówimy trzy różne sposoby reprezentowania kanałów
matematycznie, a w szczególności omówimy reprezentacje Steinspeinga, reprezentacje Kraussa i reprezentacje Choi'ego,
nazwane na cześć trzech osób, których praca była ważna w rozwoju tych różnych reprezentacji. W trzeciej i
ostatniej części lekcji omówimy matematyczny dowód, który ustala, że te trzy reprezentacje są w istocie równoważne, jak również fakt, że
wszystkie poprawnie charakteryzują definicję kanału. To naprawdę świetny dowód matematyczny moim zdaniem i mam nadzieję, że doda
jasności tym różnym prezentacjom, temu jak się ze sobą wiążą i jak działają. Zaczniemy od podstaw i
odpowiemy na pytanie: czym są kanały? Jak już sugerowałem na początku lekcji, kanały opisują zmiany –
konkretnie dyskretne zmiany w czasie w układach przechowujących informację kwantową. Kiedy mówimy o dyskretnej zmianie w czasie,
mamy na myśli zmianę zachodzącą między dwoma odrębnymi momentami w czasie, w przeciwieństwie do
procesu ciągłego, który na przykład ma sens rozważać dla nieskończenie małych okresów czasu. Kanały obejmują użyteczne operacje, jak
operacje unitarne wykonywane przez kwantowe gate'y i circuit'y, a także zmiany wynikające z szumu. Jednak na potrzeby
tej lekcji będziemy głównie myśleć o kanałach w abstrakcyjnych kategoriach matematycznych i nie będzie szczególnej potrzeby
rozróżniania między tym, co użyteczne, a tym, co nie. Typowe nazwy dla kanałów to wielkie greckie litery fi,
psi i xi, i będziemy używać różnych liter do oznaczenia konkretnych kanałów. W prostej sytuacji, w której
mamy pewien układ w stanie opisanym przez pewną macierz gęstości ro i stosujemy do niego kanał fi, wynikiem
jest układ, którego stan jest opisany przez macierz gęstości fi(ro). Myślimy więc o danym
kanale fi jako o funkcji, którą można zastosować do macierzy gęstości określonego rozmiaru, czyli innymi słowy
do macierzy gęstości konkretnego układu, do którego stosujemy ten kanał. Istnieje kilka wymagań, które kanały muszą spełniać, aby być
uznane za prawidłowe. Po pierwsze, kanały są odwzorowaniami liniowymi. Jest to całkowicie analogiczne do sytuacji, którą mamy zarówno
w uproszczonym sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej, gdzie operacje na kwantowych wektorach stanu są z konieczności liniowe, jak
i w standardowym sformułowaniu klasycznej informacji, gdzie operacje probabilistyczne są liniowe. Możesz zakwestionować to podstawowe
wymaganie liniowości, jeśli naprawdę chcesz, ale jeśli chcemy teorii spójnej zarówno z teorią prawdopodobieństwa,
jak i wyborem reprezentowania stanów kwantowych przez macierze gęstości, to nie mamy właściwie wyboru i musimy po prostu zaakceptować, że kanały są liniowe.
Drugie wymaganie to to, że kanały przekształcają macierze gęstości w macierze gęstości. Ma to doskonały sens, bo jeśli zdecydowaliśmy się reprezentować
stany układów przez macierze gęstości i stosujemy kanał do układu w jakimś stanie, to wynik musi być prawidłowym stanem, a zatem
reprezentowanym przez macierz gęstości. Jest tu jednak bardzo ważna uwaga, mianowicie to wymaganie
musi być prawdziwe nie tylko wtedy, gdy stosujemy kanał do izolowanego układu, którego stan jest opisany przez macierz gęstości,
ale też gdy mamy układ złożony, którego stan jest opisany przez pewną macierz gęstości i stosujemy kanał tylko do
części tego układu. To są więc wymagania, które stawiamy kanałom i widzimy, że są one bardzo
analogiczne do wymagań, jakie mamy dla operacji zarówno w uproszczonym sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej, jak i w standardowym sformułowaniu
klasycznej informacji. W uproszczonym sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej operacje są reprezentowane przez macierze unitarne, bo
odpowiadają dokładnie liniowym odwzorowaniom, które zawsze przekształcają kwantowe wektory stanu w kwantowe wektory stanu dla
danego układu. Podobnie operacje probabilistyczne są reprezentowane przez macierze stochastyczne, bo to właśnie te
zawsze przekształcają wektory prawdopodobieństwa w wektory prawdopodobieństwa. Tutaj pracujemy z macierzami gęstości i istnieje
to dodatkowe wymaganie dotyczące układów złożonych, które okazuje się niepotrzebne dla kwantowych wektorów stanu
czy wektorów prawdopodobieństwa, ale poza tym wymagania są analogiczne i w pewnym sensie zostały nam narzucone przez wybór
reprezentowania stanów kwantowych przez macierze gęstości. Oto kilka dalszych szczegółów dotyczących kanałów, w tym konwencja
dotycząca tego, jak będziemy myśleć o układach wejściowych i wyjściowych kanału w tej lekcji, oraz nieco więcej szczegółów
na temat wymagania, że kanały zawsze przekształcają macierze gęstości w macierze gęstości. Po pierwsze, każdy kanał
zakładamy, że ma układ wejściowy i układ wyjściowy. Możemy nazywać te układy jak chcemy, ale przez całą tę
lekcję będę używał nazwy X dla układu wejściowego i nazwy Y dla układu wyjściowego. Koncepcyjnie kanał
przekształca układ wejściowy w układ wyjściowy, więc układy wejściowy i wyjściowy nigdy nie współistnieją jednocześnie.
Zaczynamy od X, kanał jest stosowany lub wykonywany i wynikiem jest to, że X zostało przekształcone w Y, którego stan jest
wyznaczony przez odwzorowanie liniowe skojarzone z kanałem. Układy wejściowy i wyjściowy kanału nie muszą być takie same, a w szczególności
nie muszą mieć tej samej liczby stanów klasycznych. Może jednak być tak, że układ wejściowy i wyjściowy są w rzeczywistości tym samym układem lub innymi słowy
WEBVTT
X równa się Y, w którym to przypadku po prostu wyobrażamy sobie, że fi zmienia stan układu, i rzeczywiście jest to
bardzo często sytuacja, która nas interesuje, ale ta możliwość jest spójna z pierwszym punktem w tym sensie, że nigdy nie mamy
układów wejściowego i wyjściowego istniejących jednocześnie jako dwa oddzielne układy. W każdym razie będzie wygodnie dla
celów tej lekcji używać różnych liter, mianowicie X i Y, do oznaczenia układów wejściowego i wyjściowego,
żeby ułatwić śledzenie. Teraz przejdźmy do nieco więcej szczegółów na temat wymagania, że kanały zawsze przekształcają macierze gęstości
w macierze gęstości. Załóżmy, że wprowadzamy nowy układ Z do obrazu.
Nazwijmy gamma klasycznym zbiorem stanów tego nowego układu. Wyobraź sobie teraz, że tworzymy nowy układ złożony ZX,
składający się z nowego układu wraz z układem wejściowym X kanału fi, i załóżmy, że ten układ złożony jest
w stanie opisanym przez macierz gęstości ro. Może to być dowolny stan kwantowy tej pary, ale niezależnie od stanu
zawsze jest możliwe wyrażenie macierzy gęstości ro w formie pokazanej na ekranie, gdzie zarówno A, jak i B
przebiegają po klasycznym zbiorze stanów gamma, a każde ro_AB jest pewną macierzą, której wiersze i kolumny odpowiadają temu, jaki
klasyczny zbiór stanów ma X. Nie musimy w tym miejscu nadawać temu klasycznemu zbiorowi stanów nazwy. Dla jasności: każde ro_AB niekoniecznie jest samo w sobie
macierzą gęstości, ale cała macierz ro jest z konieczności macierzą gęstości. Gdy stosujemy kanał fi do
układu X, zostaje on przekształcony w Y i zostajemy z parą ZY, a sposób, w jaki wyznaczamy
stan tej pary po wykonaniu fi na samym X, polega na ocenie odwzorowania liniowego fi na każdej z macierzy ro_A.
Innym sposobem powiedzenia tego jest to, że bierzemy iloczyn tensorowy odwzorowania fi z odwzorowaniem identyczności na macierzach kwadratowych, których wiersze i kolumny
odpowiadają gamma, co z kolei odpowiada nierobienia nic z tym nowym układem Z. Ale jest to równoważny
opis i nie wymaga zagłębiania się w szczegóły iloczynów tensorowych odwzorowań tej formy.
Działają one jednak w dość prosty sposób analogiczny do tego, jak działają dla wektorów i macierzy. Jednym ze sposobów wizualnego myślenia o tym jest
w kategoriach macierzy blokowych i jeśli zrobimy upraszczające założenie, że klasyczny zbiór stanów gamma składa się z
liczb całkowitych od 0 do N minus jeden dla pewnej dodatniej liczby całkowitej M, to staje się łatwo to wszystko zapisać, jak
pokazano tutaj. A teraz, żeby powtórzyć wymaganie, które stawiamy fi, aby było prawidłowym kanałem: musimy zawsze uzyskiwać macierz gęstości
z tego procesu, i musi to być prawdziwe niezależnie od wyboru układu Z, jak również
wyboru ro, pod warunkiem że jest to macierz gęstości. Może to wydawać się dość surowym wymaganiem i
może też wydawać się bardzo trudne do sprawdzenia, ale jak zobaczymy pod koniec lekcji, to nie jest aż tak surowe
ani trudne do sprawdzenia, a w szczególności mamy ładne matematyczne charakteryzacje tego warunku,
które są połączone z różnymi reprezentacjami, o których będziemy mówić nieco później w lekcji. Teraz przyjrzyjmy się kilku przykładom kanałów,
zaczynając od całej kategorii kanałów zwanych kanałami unitarnymi. W prostych słowach, są to operacje unitarne,
tak jak mamy w uproszczonym sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej, traktowane jako kanały. Konkretnie, załóżmy, że U jest macierzą unitarną
reprezentującą operację unitarną na układzie X. W uproszczonym sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej
mnożylibyśmy tę macierz przez dany kwantowy wektor stanu, aby określić działanie tej operacji na ten kwantowy wektor stanu. Sposób,
w jaki to działa dla macierzy gęstości, polega na pomnożeniu macierzy gęstości z lewej strony przez U i z prawej przez U
dagger. W kategoriach matematycznych tę operację nazywamy sprzężeniem przez macierz U. Jest to spójne z tym, że ket_psi bra_psi
jest macierzą gęstości opisującą stan reprezentowany przez kwantowy wektor stanu psi i to dość
łatwo sprawdzić, że gdybyśmy wykonali U na kwantowym wektorze stanu ket_psi, to dostalibyśmy U * ket_psi, a jego
reprezentacja w postaci macierzy gęstości jest dana przez ten wektor pomnożony przez jego sprzężone transponowanie, czyli U * ket_psi * bra_psi * U
dagger, gdy oceniamy sprzężone transponowanie U * ket_psi. Tak więc sposób, w jaki ten kanał jest zdefiniowany,
ma sens dla stanów czystych, a gdy połączymy to z liniowością, widzimy, że ma sens dla macierzy gęstości
w ogólności, ze względu na fakt, że każda macierz gęstości może być wyrażona jako wypukła kombinacja stanów czystych.
Ta definicja zawsze daje nam prawidłowy kanał dla dowolnego wyboru operacji unitarnej U. W szczególności sprzężenie przez
macierz unitarną nie zmienia śladu macierzy i jeśli sprzężymy dowolną macierz dodatnio
półokreśloną przez dowolną macierz, otrzymamy inną macierz dodatnio półokreśloną, i to dość łatwo wykazać
bezpośrednio z definicji macierzy dodatnio półokreślonych. Macierze gęstości są więc zawsze odwzorowywane na macierze gęstości
i wszystko to pozostaje prawdziwe nawet gdy bierzemy iloczyn tensorowy U z macierzą jednostkową dowolnego rozmiaru, co jest równoważne
stosowaniu tego kanału tylko do części układu złożonego. Oto naprawdę prosty przykład kanału unitarnego: załóżmy, że
U jest macierzą jednostkową. Jest to oczywiście prawidłowy kanał zwany kanałem jednostkowym, który nic nie robi.
Nierobienie czegokolwiek jest z pewnością operacją liniową i jeśli zaczniemy od macierzy gęstości i nic z nią nie zrobimy,
nadal będzie macierzą gęstości, więc jest to prawidłowy kanał. Ludzie używają różnych symboli do oznaczania tego kanału;
czasem jest to dokładnie ten sam symbol, co dla macierzy jednostkowej, co może być nieco mylące, ale zazwyczaj nie jest. Tutaj używam
liter ID, skrót od identity, żeby uniknąć pomyłek, i ta notacja też jest dość powszechna. Może wydawać się
bardzo nudnym kanałem, ale w kontekście transmisji informacji jest to w rzeczywistości doskonały kanał, w którym
odbiorca dostaje dokładnie to, co nadawca wysyła, co zazwyczaj jest tym, czego się chce. Innym sposobem uzyskania
wielu przykładów kanałów jest branie wypukłych kombinacji kanałów, czyli innymi słowy uśrednianie ich
razem, i fakt, że możemy to robić, jest ważnym aspektem kanałów. Żeby wyjaśnić to bardziej szczegółowo, zacznijmy od dwóch kanałów F0 i F1,
powiedzmy, wraz z liczbą rzeczywistą p między 0 a 1. Dla jasności zakładamy, że te dwa kanały mają
ten sam układ wejściowy X, jak i ten sam układ wyjściowy Y. Rozważmy teraz co się dzieje, gdy decydujemy się
stosować pierwszy kanał F0 z prawdopodobieństwem p, a w pozostałych przypadkach z prawdopodobieństwem 1 minus p stosujemy
drugi kanał F1. Na przykład może losowo wybieramy bit z tymi prawdopodobieństwami i używamy tego losowego
bitu do określenia, który kanał zastosować. Robiąc to, efektywnie stosujemy nowy kanał, który możemy nazwać psi,
dany przez wypukłą kombinację dwóch kanałów, od których zaczęliśmy, co możemy wyrazić jak zapisano
na ekranie. Zawsze możemy brać liniowe kombinacje odwzorowań liniowych w ten sposób, a sposób, w jaki liniowa
WEBVTT
kombinacja odwzorowań liniowych jest zdefiniowana dla danego wejścia, polega na wzięciu tej samej liniowej kombinacji wyjść.
Może to wyglądać trywialnie, ale ma sens: wyjście, które dostajemy z tego hipotetycznego scenariusza, to po prostu ważona średnia
wyjść, które dostalibyśmy z dwóch oryginalnych kanałów. Niemniej jest to nowy kanał i
jeśli F0 i F1 były istotnie prawidłowymi kanałami, to z pewnością to nowe odwzorowanie też będzie prawidłowym kanałem. Innym sposobem powiedzenia tego
w kategoriach matematycznych jest to, że zbiór wszystkich kanałów od danego układu wejściowego do danego układu wyjściowego jest
wypukły i jest to ważna właściwość matematyczna kanałów. Możemy to robić bardziej ogólnie: jeśli mamy M kanałów F0 do F_,
powiedzmy, wraz z wektorem prawdopodobieństwa mówiącym nam, jakie jest prawdopodobieństwo dla każdego kanału, to otrzymujemy nowy kanał przez odpowiednie uśrednienie kanałów.
W pewnym sensie jest to niewyczerpane źródło nowych kanałów. Na przykład klasa tak zwanych mieszanych kanałów unitarnych to to,
co dostajemy biorąc wypukłe kombinacje kanałów unitarnych. Tzn. jeśli mamy M macierzy unitarnych U0 do U_,
wszystkich tego samego rozmiaru, wraz z wektorem prawdopodobieństwa, to jeśli weźmiemy ważoną średnią kanałów
odpowiadających poszczególnym macierzom unitarnym, jak pokazano tutaj na ekranie, to dostaniemy kanał. Kanały,
które można tak zapisać, nazywamy mieszanymi kanałami unitarnymi. Nie każdy kanał jest mieszanym kanałem unitarnym, nie możemy uzyskać
w ten sposób każdego kanału, ale pojawiają się one dość często. Następnie przyjrzymy się kilku konkretnym
przykładom kanałów. Będą to wszystko przykłady kanałów z jednego qubit'a do jednego qubit'a, które nazywamy kanałami
qubitowymi. Pierwszy z nich to kanał resetu qubit'a i idea polega na tym, że ten kanał resetuje qubit
do stanu zero. Tutaj używamy wielkiej greckiej litery Lambda do oznaczenia tego kanału i sposobem na zapamiętanie, co ten kanał robi, jest
myślenie o sferze Blocha. Wielka Lambda trochę wygląda jak strzałka skierowana do góry, a stan zero jest na szczycie sfery Blocha, jakby
wskazywał na lokalizację wyjścia. Sposób, w jaki jest zdefiniowany matematycznie, to Lambda(ro) równa się ślad(ro) razy ket_0 bra_0. Więc
jeśli ocenimy to na dowolnej macierzy gęstości ro, dostaniemy stan zero jako macierz gęstości. Można się zastanawiać,
dlaczego potrzebujemy śladu – czy nie możemy po prostu zdefiniować Lambda(ro) jako ket_0 bra_0 bez śladu(ro) z przodu?
Odpowiedź brzmi nie – kanały muszą być odwzorowaniami liniowymi i nie byłoby liniowe, gdybyśmy usunęli ślad(ro). Pamiętaj też, że
czasem potrzebujemy wiedzieć, jak kanał działa jako odwzorowanie liniowe na wejściach niebędących macierzami gęstości, na przykład jak
widzieliśmy wcześniej: jeśli chcemy wiedzieć, co kanał robi, gdy stosujemy go do układu złożonego, musimy
ocenić ten kanał na poszczególnych blokach większej macierzy blokowej, a mimo że cała macierz blokowa może być
macierzą gęstości, poszczególne bloki na ogół nie będą. Zobaczmy więc dokładnie, co ten kanał robi, gdy stosujemy go
do tylko jednej części układu złożonego, a konkretnie co robi, gdy stosujemy go do jednego z dwóch qubit'ów tworzących
ebit. Konkretnie, załóżmy że A i B są qubit'ami, które jako para są w stanie Bella phi_plus i stosujemy Lambda
do powiedzmy pierwszego qubit'a A. Żeby dowiedzieć się, co się stanie, najpierw wyraźmy stan phi_plus jako macierz gęstości i
na potrzeby tego przykładu użyjmy notacji bezpośredniej. Oto stan phi_plus jako kwantowy wektor stanu i oto co dostajemy, gdy
pomnożymy ten wektor przez jego sprzężone transponowanie i rozwinniemy wszystko. Możemy następnie zastosować kanał do pierwszego qubit'a i ocenić, co dostajemy. Oto
Lambda zastosowane do pierwszego qubit'a i oto co dostajemy, gdy oceniamy każdy z wyrazów: ślad(ket_0 bra_0) wynosi jeden
i tak samo ślad(ket_1 bra_1), więc w tych dwóch przypadkach wyjściem kanału jest ket_0 bra_0 i to wyjaśnia
dwa wyrazy w odpowiedzi. Ślad(ket_0 bra_1) z kolei wynosi zero, podobnie jak ślad(ket_1 bra_0),
więc te dwa wyrazy dają zero i nie wnoszą nic do odpowiedzi. Możemy teraz nieco uprościć
i dostajemy stan zero dla pierwszego qubit'a A i stan całkowicie mieszany dla
drugiego qubit'a B. Zauważ w szczególności, że nie dostaliśmy stanu plus dla B, co nie byłoby koniecznie
złym przypuszczeniem, gdybyśmy nic nie wiedzieli o macierzach gęstości i patrzyliśmy tylko na reprezentację kwantowego wektora stanu. Ale tak
nie działa ten kanał i nie ma kanału, który mógłby działać w ten sposób. Kanał Lambda nazywa się kanałem resetu qubit'a, ale
jego działanie bardziej przypomina wyrzucenie wejściowego qubit'a do kosza i zastąpienie go świeżym qubit'em w stanie zero. Ale tak w istocie jest to
jedyny kanał qubitowy, który zawsze daje na wyjściu stan zero. Oto kolejny przykład kanału qubitowego, zwany
całkowicie defazującym kanałem. Ten jest oznaczany przez Delta i działa w ten sposób, że pozostawia elementy diagonalne
dowolnej macierzy 2x2 bez zmian i zeruje elementy pozadiagonalne. Delta jest greckim odpowiednikiem litery D w
alfabecie łacińskim i jest skrótem od „diagonalny", co jest jednym ze sposobów zapamiętania, co ten kanał robi. Możemy
alternatywnie wyrazić ten kanał używając notacji bezpośredniej, jak pokazano na ekranie, i dla jasności wyjście
jest zawsze macierzą 2x2, więc w szczególności dwa zera na wyjściu odnoszą się do zerowej macierzy 2x2. Często
tak robimy i widzieliśmy to wcześniej w tej serii: symbol zero jest zazwyczaj używany, być może niejednoznacznie, dla oznaczenia zerowego
elementu czegokolwiek, o czym mówimy, niezależnie czy to skalar, wektor, macierz czy cokolwiek innego. Zróbmy to samo co poprzednio dla
kanału resetu qubit'a i zobaczmy co się dzieje, gdy stosujemy ten kanał do połowy ebitu. Konfiguracja jest ta sama, więc nie będę
przez to przechodzić, a wynik to stan pokazany na ekranie, który jest zasadniczo wspólnym losowym bitem. Tak więc
ten kanał w zasadzie przekształcił ebit w doskonale skorelowaną parę klasycznych losowych bitów
i jest to spójne z bardziej ogólną interpretacją tego kanału: zerując elementy pozadiagonalne macierzy gęstości, efektywnie
wyrzucamy kwantową część macierzy gęstości, pozostawiając diagonalną macierz gęstości reprezentującą
klasyczny stan probabilistyczny. Innym sposobem myślenia o tym jest to, że ten kanał reprezentuje doskonały bezszumowy kanał klasyczny transmitujący bit.
Jeśli więc wstawimy stan zero, stan jeden lub wypukłą kombinację tych dwóch stanów do kanału, to ten stan wychodzi niezmieniony. Ale jeśli próbujesz
wstawić stan kwantowy, jak na przykład stan plus, to jest tak, jakby kanał mierzył ten stan pomiarem w standardowej bazie, a następnie
transmitował klasyczny wynik. Ostatni przykład kanału qubitowego to całkowicie depolaryzujący kanał.
Co ten kanał robi, to zawsze wypisuje całkowicie mieszany stan, więc jest podobny w pewnym sensie do kanału resetu qubit'a,
z tym że dostajemy raczej mniej użyteczny całkowicie mieszany stan zamiast zainicjowanego qubit'a. Naturalnym sposobem
myślenia o tym kanale jest to, że reprezentuje ekstremalną formę szumu i jeśli chodzi o kanały qubitowe,
to nie ma nic bardziej zaszumionego. Nie mam dobrego mnemonica do podzielenia się, który pomagałby zapamiętać, co ten robi, poza tym, że Omega jest ostatnią
literą greckiego alfabetu i jest czasem kojarzona z końcem wszystkich rzeczy, i może właśnie to się dzieje
WEBVTT
z wszystkimi qubit'ami w końcu jeśli chodzi o szum. Jest dość ekstremalny, ale jedną rzeczą, którą możemy zrobić, to rozważyć wypukłą
kombinację tego kanału i kanału jednostkowego z być może małym prawdopodobieństwem epsilon dla całkowitej
depolaryzacji. Jest to mniej ekstremalna forma szumu, w której dany stan qubit'owy będzie w przeważającej mierze pozostawiony bez zmian, ale istnieje
małe prawdopodobieństwo, że stanie się całkowicie mieszany. Geometrycznie możemy myśleć o tym jako o lekkim skurczeniu sfery Blocha ku środkowi.
Nawiasem mówiąc, możemy zrobić coś podobnego z całkowicie defazującym kanałem, żeby modelować proces dekoherencji na przykład, gdzie rzeczy
stają się nieco bardziej klasyczne przez jakiś proces. To są więc trzy podstawowe przykłady kanałów qubitowych i będziemy
do nich wracać głównie jako do źródła przykładów przez resztę lekcji. Następnie omówimy matematyczne
reprezentacje kanałów, zaczynając od podstawowego pytania: odwzorowania liniowe z wektorów do wektorów zawsze można
reprezentować przez macierze w znany sposób, polegający na tym, że działanie odwzorowania liniowego jest opisane przez mnożenie macierzy
przez wektor. Ale kanały są odwzorowaniami liniowymi z macierzy do macierzy, a nie z wektorów do wektorów, więc
jak ogólnie możemy wyrażać kanały w kategoriach matematycznych? Czasem dla specjalnych kanałów będziemy mieć prostą formułę
opisującą je, i tak było w przypadku przykładów kanałów qubitowych, które już omówiliśmy, ale to nie jest
praktyczne ogólnie, bo nie zawsze będzie tak ładna formuła. Dla porównania, w uproszczonym
sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej używamy macierzy unitarnych do reprezentowania operacji na kwantowych wektorach stanu.
Każda macierz unitarna reprezentuje prawidłową operację i każdą prawidłową operację można wyrazić jako macierz unitarną. Więc
w istocie pytanie brzmi: jak to robimy dla kanałów? I odpowiedź jest taka, że istnieje w istocie wiele sposobów reprezentowania
kanałów w kategoriach matematycznych. W szczególności omówimy trzy różne sposoby reprezentowania kanałów,
nazwane na cześć trzech osób, których praca odegrała ważną rolę w ich rozwoju: Steinspring, Krauss i Choi.
Najpierw zobaczymy, jak działają te różne reprezentacje, a następnie w ostatniej części lekcji zobaczymy, jak te trzy reprezentacje wiążą się ze sobą i
w szczególności jak możemy między nimi konwertować. Zobaczymy też, że te reprezentacje precyzyjnie ujmują wymagania, jakie stawiamy kanałom,
mianowicie że są to odwzorowania liniowe i że zawsze przekształcają macierze gęstości w macierze gęstości, nawet gdy
są stosowane do tylko jednej części układu złożonego. Pierwsza są reprezentacje Steinspeinga. William Forrest Stein
spring był matematykiem, który nie pracował nad informacją kwantową, a reprezentacje Steinspringa, tak jak je opiszę,
są w pewnym sensie tylko pochodną jego pracy nad teorią operatorów w latach 50. XX wieku. Ale ta praca była z pewnością
ważną częścią rozwoju matematyki, na której opierają się kanały kwantowe. Idea stojąca za tym sposobem reprezentowania kanałów polega na tym, że każdy
kanał można zaimplementować w pewien sposób, który teraz opiszę. Najpierw tworzymy układ złożony składający się z
wejścia do dowolnego kanału, który implementujemy, wraz z zainicjowanym układem roboczym. Następnie
na układzie złożonym wykonywana jest operacja unitarna i na koniec ta część wynikowego układu złożonego,
która odpowiada wyjściu kanału, jest pozostawiana lub wyprowadzana, a reszta jest odrzucana lub tracowana. Wygodnie
wyrazić to w formie diagramu i najprostsze jest zaczęcie od szczególnego przypadku, w którym układy wejściowy i
wyjściowy są takie same. Ten diagram jest zresztą dokładnie jak diagram obwodu kwantowego, z tym że przewody
reprezentują dowolne układy, a nie koniecznie pojedyncze qubit'y. Zaczynamy więc z układem wejściowym X w jakimś
stanie ro, wprowadzamy zainicjowany układ roboczy W i w tym diagramie zakładam, że zero jest stanem klasycznym
W, a ket_0 traktujemy jako zainicjowany stan układu, ale moglibyśmy alternatywnie ustalić dowolny czysty stan
W i traktować go jako zainicjowany stan. Następnie wykonujemy pewną operację unitarną na parze WX i potem
trasujemy układ roboczy i wyprowadzamy X. Tutaj w diagramie nawiasem mówiąc używam symbolu masy z elektrotechniki
do wskazania, że W jest odrzucane. Nie jest to koniecznie konwencjonalne i nie znajdziesz tego symbolu w Qiskit;
tam po prostu ignorujesz qubit'y, którymi nie jesteś zainteresowany. Chodzi o to, że chcę mieć symbol, który wyraźnie wskazuje,
że odrzucamy układ na potrzeby tej dyskusji. Ogólnie niekoniecznie potrzebujemy, żeby
układy wejściowy i wyjściowy były takie same, więc możemy mieć na przykład układ wyjściowy Y wraz z systemem odpadowym
G, który jest trasowany. Żeby U było unitarne, musi być macierzą kwadratową, więc zakładamy,
że para G, Y razem ma tę samą liczbę stanów klasycznych co para WX. Na przykład może te układy
składają się z qubit'ów i układ wejściowy X składa się z 5 qubit'ów, a W z 10 qubit'ów, powiedzmy. U jest więc operacją unitarną
na 15 qubit'ach. Może się wtedy okazać, że Y składa się z zaledwie czterech qubit'ów, co oznacza, że G składa się z 11 qubit'ów.
A może to wcale nie są qubit'y – ważne jest tylko, żeby WX razem i GY razem miały tę samą liczbę
stanów klasycznych, żeby U mogło być unitarne. Opis kanału w ten sposób nazywa się reprezentacją Steinspringa kanału. Teraz
jest dość proste do uzasadnienia, że każde odwzorowanie fi, które można opisać w ten sposób, jest w istocie prawidłowym kanałem.
W szczególności jeśli zaczniemy od macierzy gęstości, a następnie dołączymy dodatkowy układ roboczy, to z pewnością
zostaniemy z macierzą gęstości. Już zauważyliśmy, że stosowanie operacji unitarnej daje nam prawidłowy kanał i
jeśli mamy macierz gęstości układu złożonego i trasujemy jeden z układów, to znowu zostaniemy z macierzą gęstości. Więc gdy złożymy
te kroki, będziemy gwarantowali, że zawsze przekształca macierze gęstości w macierze gęstości, i jest też liniowe.
Co wcale nie jest jasne w tym miejscu, to że każdy kanał może być rzeczywiście zaimplementowany w ten sposób dla pewnego wyboru
układu roboczego, układu odpadowego, jak również operacji unitarnej U. Ale to jest prawdą i zobaczymy
dlaczego pod koniec lekcji. Oto przykład reprezentacji Steinspringa dla całkowicie
defazującego kanału qubitowego. Dla jasności, teraz przewody są qubit'ami i jest to zwykła bramka CNOT (controlled-NOT).
Jest bardzo prosta: wejściowy qubit jest na górze i wprowadzamy roboczy qubit zainicjowany do stanu zero.
Następnie wykonujemy operację controlled-NOT, gdzie wejściowy qubit jest kontrolą, a roboczy qubit jest
celem, a następnie roboczy qubit jest trasowany. Intuicyjnie ma sens,
że powinno to implementować całkowicie defazujący kanał, bo bramka controlled-NOT trochę działa jak pomiar w standardowej bazie górnego
qubit'a przez kopiowanie jego klasycznego stanu na dolny qubit, a następnie wynik jest wyrzucany.
Ale możemy też przeprowadzić obliczenie i oczywiście dobrze jest to zrobić, bo naprawdę
WEBVTT
nie powinniśmy zbytnio ufać naszej intuicji. Możemy zacząć od zapisania reprezentacji macierzy gęstości dwóch
qubit'ów po wprowadzeniu roboczego qubit'a i zwróć uwagę, że używamy konwencji kolejności qubit'ów, jak
zwykle, gdzie dolny qubit jest lewym, a górny qubit jest prawym. Możemy wyrazić tę macierz gęstości
wprost jako rzeczywistą macierz 4x4, jak pokazano na ekranie, a następnie obliczamy efekt,
jaki bramka controlled-NOT ma na tę macierz gęstości, sprzęgając przez macierz unitarną skojarzoną z tą
bramką, pamiętając o konwencji kolejności qubit'ów. To jest więc właściwa macierz unitarna,
a wynik jest pokazany tutaj. Bramka controlled-NOT
przestawiła elementy naszej oryginalnej macierzy, więc teraz potencjalnie niezerowe elementy są w
czterech rogach. Pozostaje obliczyć ślad częściowy i moglibyśmy to zrobić bezpośrednio z macierzy, ale
alternatywą jest konwersja do notacji bezpośredniej, jak pokazano na ekranie, a wtedy staje się dość łatwe ocenić,
co się dzieje, gdy trasujemy qubit po lewej wewnątrz każdego wyrazu, a wynikiem jest to, że przeżywają tylko
wyrazy odpowiadające elementom diagonalnym ro, i tak defazowaliśmy qubit zgodnie z
oczekiwaniami. Jak zawsze, sprawdź to samodzielnie we własnym tempie, jeśli chcesz. To dobry
przykład do ćwiczenia pracy z macierzami gęstości i śladami częściowymi.
To nie jest jedyny sposób implementacji całkowicie defazującego kanału. Oto alternatywna reprezentacja Steinspringa dla tego
kanału. Nie będę szczegółowo omawiał obliczeń w tym filmie, ale pokażę je krótko, gdybyś chciał zatrzymać film i przyjrzeć się
bliżej. Sposób działania jest podobny do pierwszego, ale szczegóły są
inne. Tym razem zaczynamy z bramką Hadamard na roboczym qubit'ie, która wprowadza go w stan plus, i jeśli
rozwinniemy iloczyn tensorowy, dostaniemy macierz pokazaną na ekranie. Żeby zastosować bramkę controlled-Z,
sprzęgamy przez skojarzoną macierz unitarną i wynikiem tego jest wstrzyknięcie kilku minusów do
macierzy, a w szczególności ostatni wiersz i ostatnia kolumna są pomnożone przez -1.
I tym razem konwersja do notacji bezpośredniej byłaby dość nieporządna, więc obliczymy ślad częściowy
bezpośrednio. Gdy trasujemy pierwszy z dwóch qubit'ów, dostajemy sumę dwóch diagonalnych bloków 2x2
i wynik końcowy to znowu, że zdefazowaliśmy qubit. To było szybkie i jeśli nie jesteś
przyzwyczajony do takich obliczeń, to rób to powoli. Szybkość nie jest tu ważna.
Żeby dokończyć ten przykład, wspomnijmy, że za tą implementacją kryje się dość prosta idea,
ładnie wyrażona przez ostatni krok obliczeń, który właśnie przelecieliśmy. Bardziej zwięzłym sposobem powiedzenia tego
jest to, że jeśli uśrednimy daną qubitową macierz gęstości z tą macierzą gęstości sprzężoną przez macierz Pauliego Z, to
jest to to samo, co defazowanie. Więc całkowicie defazujący kanał jest mieszanym kanałem unitarnym,
w którym albo nic nie robimy, czyli wykonujemy operację jednostkową, albo wykonujemy bramkę Z, każde
z prawdopodobieństwem 1/2. Dobrze wiedzieć. Podsumowując, mamy dwie różne
reprezentacje Steinspringa całkowicie defazującego kanału, i to mówi nam coś ważnego, mianowicie że reprezentacje Steinspringa
nie są unikalne i w istocie dla dowolnego kanału jest ich nieskończenie wiele. Następnie omówimy reprezentacje Kraussa
kanałów, które dają nam wygodny formulaiczny sposób wyrażania kanałów przez mnożenie macierzy
i dodawanie. Reprezentacje Kraussa są named po Carlu Kraussie, który jest fizykiem, który między innymi
opracował wiele podstawowych matematycznych szczegółów kanałów i ogólnego sformułowania informacji kwantowej szerzej. Ogólnie
reprezentacja Kraussa jest wyrażeniem kanału w formie pokazanej tutaj na ekranie. W szczególności mamy
zbiór macierzy, tu nazwanych A_0 do A_ dla pewnej dodatniej liczby całkowitej N, które określają
działanie kanału na dowolnym wejściu ro zgodnie z formułą. Krótko: sprzęgamy ro przez każdą z tych macierzy,
często nazywanych macierzami Kraussa w tym kontekście, a następnie sumujemy wynik i to daje wyjście. Wszystkie te macierze muszą mieć
te same wymiary, a konkretnie ich kolumny muszą odpowiadać stanom klasycznym układu wejściowego i
wiersze muszą odpowiadać stanom klasycznym układu wyjściowego. Jeśli tak jest, to gdy bierzemy iloczyn A_K * ro * A_K^† dla dowolnego
wyboru K, dostajemy macierz kwadratową, której wiersze i kolumny odpowiadają stanom klasycznym układu wyjściowego,
i ma sens, że wyrażenie daje macierz gęstości układu wyjściowego. Nie jest jednak tak,
że dla dowolnego wyboru tych macierzy Kraussa dostajemy prawidłowy kanał. Jest jednak dość prosty
warunek na macierze, który gwarantuje, że dostaniemy prawidłowy kanał, i ten warunek to formuła wyświetlona tutaj.
Konkretnie, jeśli zsumujemy iloczyn A_K^† * A_K dla wszystkich wartości K,
to musimy dostać macierz jednostkową, i będzie to macierz jednostkowa, której wiersze i kolumny odpowiadają
stanom klasycznym układu wejściowego. Ten warunek musi być więc spełniony, żeby odwzorowanie zdefiniowane przez
pierwsze równanie było prawidłowym kanałem, i okazuje się, że każdy kanał ma w istocie reprezentację o tej postaci,
pod warunkiem że N jest wystarczająco duże. Oto kilka przykładów reprezentacji Kraussa,
zaczynając od kanału resetu qubit'a. Możemy uzyskać reprezentację Kraussa dla tego kanału używając
dwóch macierzy Kraussa: ket_0 bra_0 i ket_0 bra_1, więc N jest równe dwa w tym przykładzie.
Możemy wstawić te wybory do ogólnej formuły i mamy tylko dwa wyrazy, więc łatwo wypisać sumę,
i jeśli upraszczamy i rozpoznajemy, że wyrażenie w nawiasach to ślad ro, to widzimy, że dostajemy
kanał resetu qubit'a. Możemy też sprawdzić, że wymagany warunek na tych macierzach jest spełniony, i to jest prosta kwestia wstawienia macierzy Kraussa
do równania i oceny, a dostajemy macierz jednostkową, jak wymagane. Dla kolejnego przykładu ponownie przyjrzyjmy się
całkowicie defazującemu kanałowi. Przyjęcie macierzy ket_0 bra_0 i ket_1 bra_1 działa i można to sprawdzić
rozwijając sumę i widząc dość bezpośrednio, że dostajemy to, co potrzebujemy, a wymagany warunek jest spełniony. Alternatywą
jest wzięcie A_0 jako macierzy jednostkowej podzielonej przez pierwiastek z 2 i A_1 jako
Sigma_Z podzielonego przez pierwiastek z 2, i jeśli oceniamy, widzimy, że znowu dostajemy całkowicie defazujący kanał, na podstawie obserwacji,
WEBVTT
którą zrobiliśmy wcześniej w lekcji o tym kanale, a wymagany warunek jest dość prosty do
sprawdzenia jako ćwiczenie, jeśli uznasz to za pomocne. Rozważmy całkowicie depolaryzujący kanał,
który dla każdej macierzy gęstości na wejściu wyprowadza całkowicie mieszany stan. Dla tego kanału potrzebne są cztery macierze Kraussa;
nie można wymyślić reprezentacji Kraussa, gdzie N wynosi trzy lub mniej. Oto jeden wybór, który działa, i
oto inny, więc ćwiczenie polega na weryfikacji, że te wybory działają, a także na sprawdzeniu, że wymagany warunek
jest spełniony. Warto zauważyć, że druga alternatywa w zasadzie mówi, że można całkowicie depolaryzować qubit, innymi słowy
całkowicie go zrandomizować, przez losowe wybranie jednej z czterech macierzy Pauliego łącznie z macierzą jednostkową i zastosowanie
odpowiedniej operacji unitarnej do qubit'a. Więc całkowicie depolaryzujący kanał jest kolejnym przykładem mieszanego
kanału unitarnego. Ostatnia z trzech reprezentacji kanałów, którą omówimy, to reprezentacja Choi'ego. Man-Duen Choi
jest matematykiem, który pracuje nad teorią macierzy i innymi tematami, a reprezentacja Choi'ego jest named na jego cześć,
na podstawie naprawdę eleganckiej pracy, którą opublikował w 1975 roku, która w pewnym sensie łączy to wszystko razem. Reprezentacja Choi'ego
kanału fi to pojedyncza macierz, tradycyjnie oznaczana J(fi), i konkretnie jeśli
układ wejściowy ma N stanów klasycznych, a układ wyjściowy ma M stanów klasycznych, to reprezentacja Choi'ego fi będzie
macierzą kwadratową N*M na N*M. Zanim powiem ci dokładnie, jak ta macierz jest zdefiniowana, chciałbym wspomnieć o kilku
jej kluczowych właściwościach, które motywują reprezentację w sposób, którego sama definicja może nie robić, przynajmniej
na powierzchni. Po pierwsze, w przeciwieństwie do zarówno reprezentacji Steinspringa, jak i reprezentacji Kraussa, reprezentacja Choi'ego
jest tzw. wierną reprezentacją, co oznacza, że każdy kanał ma dokładnie jedną, i to jest dość ważne,
bo mówi, że dwa kanały są takie same wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy ich reprezentacje Choi'ego są takie same. Więc jeśli
masz dwa różne opisy kanałów, takie jak dwie różne reprezentacje Steinspringa lub dwie różne reprezentacje Kraussa, czy może jedną z każdego,
i chcesz wiedzieć, czy w istocie są one tym samym kanałem, możesz po prostu obliczyć reprezentację Choi'ego i
sprawdzić, czy są równe. Druga właściwość to to, że są proste warunki do sprawdzenia na reprezentacji Choi'ego, które są prawdziwe wtedy i tylko
wtedy, gdy mamy prawidłowy kanał. Ta właściwość nie jest aż tak wyjątkowa – możemy to samo powiedzieć o innych dwóch reprezentacjach – ale jest to dobra właściwość
mieć i omówimy ją dalej. Jeszcze jedna rzecz do zauważenia na temat reprezentacji Choi'ego jest taka, że choć reprezentujemy
kanał przez macierz, ta macierz nie reprezentuje bezpośrednio kanału jako odwzorowania liniowego. W rzeczy samej, bardziej naturalne jest
skojarzenie reprezentacji Choi'ego z macierzą gęstości reprezentującą pewien stan
niż myślenie o reprezentacji Choi'ego jako opisującej odwzorowanie liniowe. Jest jednak możliwe odtworzenie działania kanału z jego
reprezentacji Choi'ego używając dość prostej formuły, ale nie tak prostej jak zwykłe mnożenie macierzy.
Tyle wstępu, przejdźmy do właściwej definicji. Załóżmy, że mamy kanał fi z układu X do układu Y
i załóżmy, że klasyczny zbiór stanów układu wejściowego X to Sigma. Nie będziemy musieli odwoływać się do klasycznego zbioru stanów układu wyjściowego, więc
w definicji nie ma potrzeby go nazywać. Reprezentacja Choi'ego fi jest następnie zdefiniowana przez wyrażenie
pokazane tutaj na ekranie. Mamy sumę po wszystkich klasycznych stanach A i B dla układu wejściowego i sumujemy
ket_A bra_B w iloczynie tensorowym z kanałem fi zastosowanym do ket_A bra_B. Więc ta
reprezentacja jest zdefiniowana przez formułę i jest kilka różnych sposobów myślenia o tej formule. Zanim je omówię jednak,
wspomnijmy, że czasem reprezentacja Choi'ego jest zdefiniowana w nieco inny sposób, gdzie kolejność dwóch czynników tensorowych jest odwrócona, co oznacza,
że fi(ket_A bra) pojawia się jako pierwszy czynnik tensorowy zamiast drugi, ale te dwa sposoby robienia tego są
równoważne z dokładnością do tej prostej symetrii. Oznacza to jednak, że gdy używasz tej reprezentacji, dobrze jest
wyjaśnić, którą kolejność stosujesz. Ta kolejność to ta używana w Qiskit i jest też lepsza do
opisywania reprezentacji wizualnie w kategoriach macierzy blokowych, więc z niej będziemy korzystać. Żeby być bardziej precyzyjnym w opisie macierzy blokowej,
jeśli założymy, że klasyczny zbiór stanów Sigma składa się z liczb całkowitych od zera do N minus jeden
dla pewnej dodatniej liczby całkowitej N, to możemy alternatywnie zapisać J(fi) jako macierz blokową, jak pokazano tutaj na
ekranie. Innymi słowy, reprezentacja Choi'ego fi to macierz, którą dostajemy oceniając fi na każdej z
macierzy wejściowych, które mają dokładnie jeden element równy jeden, ze wszystkimi pozostałymi elementami zerowymi, a następnie układamy je
w macierz w dość naturalny sposób. Może nie jest a priori jasne, dlaczego chcielibyśmy tworzyć taką macierz, ale okazuje się,
że jest ona bardzo użyteczna. Jedną rzeczą do zauważenia jest to, że zbiór zawierający macierze ket_A bra_B, gdy
A i B przebiegają po wszystkich liczbach całkowitych od 0 do N minus jeden, tworzy bazę dla przestrzeni wszystkich macierzy N na N. Więc jeśli
masz tę macierz, możesz z pewnością określić, co fi robi z dowolną macierzą N na N przez liniowość,
konkretnie biorąc odpowiednie liniowe kombinacje bloków. Macierz J(fi) w istocie unikatowo
wyznacza fi jako odwzorowanie liniowe. Innym sposobem myślenia o reprezentacji Choi'ego kanału jest to,
że reprezentuje ona stan jako macierz gęstości, gdy jest znormalizowana, konkretnie przez podzielenie przez liczbę
stanów klasycznych układu wejściowego, którą nadal oznaczam przez małe N. Zawsze da to
macierz gęstości, często zwaną stanem Choi'ego kanału. Oto jak to działa bardziej szczegółowo.
Wyobraź sobie najpierw, że mamy dwie identyczne kopie układu wejściowego i rozważamy kwantowy wektor stanu s
pokazany na ekranie, który reprezentuje tzw. maksymalnie splątany stan tej pary identycznych układów.
Na przykład jeśli Sigma to alfabet binarny, to jest to stan phi_plus, ale możemy myśleć o analogicznie zdefiniowanym stanie dla
dowolnego wyboru Sigma i dostajemy stan, który jest wysoce splątany, i w istocie jest tak splątany, jak to tylko możliwe
przy tym wyborze układów. Żeby uzyskać reprezentację macierzy gęstości stanu, mnożymy wektor stanu przez jego sprzężone transponowanie jak zwykle i
tak to wygląda. Na koniec, jeśli pomyślimy o reprezentacji Choi'ego kanału podzielonej przez N, widzimy, że jest to stan,
który uzyskalibyśmy, gdybyśmy zastosowali kanał fi do drugiego układu. W formie rysunku oto
jak to wygląda: mamy dwie kopie układu X w tym maksymalnie splątanym stanie s. Kanał fi jest
stosowany do drugiego układu, który jest tym na górze na diagramie, a wynikowy stan to stan Choi'ego fi. Oczywiście normalnie nie
nadawalibyśmy tej samej nazwy dwóm różnym układom, generalnie nie jest pomocne nazywanie tych samych dwóch różnych rzeczy, ale ma to sens
WEBVTT
w tym przypadku po prostu żeby nawiązać połączenie z reprezentacjami Choi'ego. Możemy od razu wyciągnąć kilka wniosków z tego sposobu
patrzenia na reprezentacje Choi'ego. Jeden z nich jest taki, że ponieważ stan Choi'ego jest macierzą gęstości, zakładając że fi jest
prawidłowym kanałem, wnioskujemy, że reprezentacja Choi'ego fi musi być dodatnio półokreślona. Pamiętaj, że jest to
wymaganie, które stawiamy kanałom, że zawsze przekształcają macierze gęstości w macierze gęstości, i to jest
tylko jeden szczególny przypadek tego. Drugi wniosek jest taki, że jeśli weźmiemy stan Choi'ego dowolnego kanału fi i
odrzucimy układ wyjściowy Y, to musimy zostać z całkowicie mieszanym stanem na układzie wejściowym X. To
dlatego, że zastosowanie kanału do układu, a następnie wyrzucenie wynikowego układu do kosza, jest równoważne po prostu wyrzuceniu oryginalnego układu do
kosza, i gdybyśmy to zrobili z naszym maksymalnie splątanym stanem, macierzą gęstości, zostalibyśmy z macierzą jednostkową
podzieloną przez N, czyli innymi słowy całkowicie mieszanym stanem dla układu X. Idea w bardziej
matematycznych kategoriach jest taka, że złożenie dowolnego kanału ze śladem na układzie wyjściowym musi być równe śladowi na
układzie wejściowym, i dzieje się tak, bo kanały muszą zachowywać ślad z racji tego, że są odwzorowaniami liniowymi, które
zawsze przekształcają macierze gęstości w macierze gęstości. Gdy mamy to równanie, możemy wyczyścić mianownik N
z obu stron, żeby dostać nieco czystszy warunek. Słowami: wykonanie śladu częściowego na układzie wyjściowym
reprezentacji Choi'ego kanału musi dawać macierz jednostkową na układzie wejściowym. Podsumowując, reprezentacje Choi'ego
kanałów są zawsze dodatnio półokreślone i jeśli wytracimy układ wyjściowy, z konieczności
zostajemy z macierzą jednostkową na układzie wejściowym. Okazuje się, że to nie są tylko warunki konieczne, ale
są też dostateczne, co oznacza, że jeśli fi jest jakimś dowolnym odwzorowaniem liniowym i oba te warunki zachodzą,
to fi musi w istocie być prawidłowym kanałem i zobaczymy dlaczego tak jest pod koniec lekcji.
Przyjrzyjmy się kilku przykładom, zaczynając od całkowicie defazującego kanału. Żeby obliczyć reprezentację Choi'ego, wystarczy
ocenić formułę. Całkowicie defazujący kanał pozostawia ket_A bra_B bez zmian gdy A równa się B, a w przeciwnym razie wynik
to zero. Więc wyrazy sumy, które przeżywają, to te, gdzie A równa się B, a wynik jest wyrażony na
ekranie w notacji bezpośredniej. Możemy też traktować to jako macierz blokową: Delta pozostawia elementy diagonalne bez zmian i zeruje
elementy pozadiagonalne, więc zostajemy z macierzą mającą jedynki w lewym górnym i prawym dolnym rogu, ze wszystkimi
pozostałymi elementami równymi zero, i jest to spójne z pierwszym wyrażeniem. Dla kolejnego przykładu rozważmy całkowicie depolaryzujący kanał. Znowu
możemy zacząć od zapisania formuły i tak jak w poprzednim przykładzie, nie dostajemy żadnego wkładu do sumy
gdy A nie jest równe B, i tym razem gdy A równa się B, dostajemy całkowicie mieszany stan i możemy uprościć to do
1/2 razy macierz jednostkową 2x2 w iloczynie tensorowym z samą sobą, co jest 1/2 razy macierzą jednostkową 4x4.
Możemy też myśleć o tym w kategoriach macierzy blokowych i naturalnie dostajemy ten sam wynik. Na
ostatni przykład rozważmy kanał jednostkowy dla pojedynczego qubit'a. To jest łatwy: oto formuła i oczywiście
kanał jednostkowy nic nie robi i możemy traktować wynik jako dwukrotność macierzy gęstości skojarzonej ze stanem phi_plus, i jest to
spójne z tym, czego oczekujemy myśląc o stanie Choi'ego tego kanału, i oto jest jako macierz blokowa. Zauważ w szczególności, że reprezentacja Choi'ego
kanału jednostkowego nie jest macierzą jednostkową, to jest ta macierz. Widzieliśmy teraz trzy różne
sposoby reprezentowania kanałów w kategoriach matematycznych, mianowicie reprezentacje Steinspringa, reprezentacje Kraussa i reprezentacje Choi'ego,
i mamy też definicję kanału, czyli że kanał jest odwzorowaniem liniowym, które zawsze
przekształca macierze gęstości w macierze gęstości, nawet gdy kanał jest stosowany do tylko jednej części układu złożonego. Bardzo naturalne i bardzo ważne
pytanie do zadania w tym miejscu: skąd wiemy, że te rzeczy są wszystkie równoważne? Na przykład skąd wiemy, że każde
odwzorowanie opisane przez którąkolwiek z tych reprezentacji jest w istocie prawidłowym kanałem i skąd wiemy, że nie opuszczamy żadnych kanałów? Reszta
lekcji opisuje, jak to wszystko można uzasadnić matematycznie. Jeśli jesteś gotów zaakceptować równoważność tych rzeczy i nie jesteś zainteresowany tym, jak to można
uzasadnić, to możesz swobodnie pominąć resztę filmu. Ale osobiście uważam, że argument jest dość
elegancki i jest to dobry przykład szczególnego stylu dowodu matematycznego, który pojawia się od czasu do czasu w teorii informacji kwantowej. Nie będę przechodzić
przez wszystkie szczegóły, niektóre zostawię dla ciebie lub możesz je znaleźć w pisemnych treściach do tej lekcji, gdzie wszystko jest wypisane szczegółowo,
ale mam nadzieję przedstawić dość jasny obraz tego, jak to wszystko działa. Co chcemy zrobić, to udowodnić
równoważność zbioru twierdzeń i sposobem, w jaki możemy to zrobić, jest ustawienie cyklu implikacji. W szczególności zaczniemy
od definicji kanału, co oznacza odwzorowanie liniowe, które zawsze przekształca macierze gęstości w macierze gęstości.
Z tej definicji możemy wnioskować, że reprezentacja Choi'ego tego kanału musi spełniać dwa warunki, które
już omówiliśmy, i w istocie już to zrobiliśmy – zostało to omówione w kontekście stanu Choi'ego kanału. Następnie zapominamy o wszystkim
na temat definicji i pracujemy z reprezentacją Choi'ego, i mając nasze dwa warunki na reprezentacjach Choi'ego, wnioskujemy, że musi istnieć
reprezentacja Kraussa odwzorowania fi. Następnie robimy analogiczną rzecz: zapominamy o reprezentacjach Choi'ego i pracujemy
z dowolną reprezentacją Kraussa i z niej możemy wnioskować, że musi istnieć reprezentacja Steinspringa dla odwzorowania fi. I nawiasem mówiąc, te
argumenty będą w pewnym sensie mechaniczne, co pozwala nam faktycznie wykonywać konwersje zgodnie ze strzałkami dla konkretnych kanałów, jeśli chcemy
to zrobić. Ostatnia implikacja to wnioskowanie, że jeśli mamy reprezentację Steinspringa dla odwzorowania fi, to
to odwzorowanie musi w istocie być prawidłowym kanałem, i znowu już to zrobiliśmy – tym razem w kontekście representacji
Steinspringa. Łącznie te cztery implikacje ujawniają, że te cztery rzeczy są wszystkie równoważne, bo można zacząć od dowolnej z nich i
podążać za implikacjami tranzytywnie, żeby dotrzeć do dowolnej z pozostałych. Zaczniemy od pierwszej implikacji,
która mówi, że jeśli mamy kanał fi, czyli odwzorowanie liniowe, które zawsze przekształca macierze gęstości w macierze gęstości, to ma ono reprezentację Choi'ego,
która spełnia dwa warunki, które wcześniej zidentyfikowaliśmy, mianowicie że jest dodatnio półokreślona
i że gdy wytracimy układ wyjściowy, dostajemy macierz jednostkową na układzie wejściowym. Jak wspomniałem przed chwilą,
już omówiliśmy tę implikację w kontekście stanów Choi'ego. W szczególności gdy dzielimy reprezentację Choi'ego kanału przez N – liczbę
stanów klasycznych układu wejściowego – dostajemy macierz gęstości, a ponadto zredukowany stan układu
wejściowego X dla tego stanu to całkowicie mieszany stan, czyli innymi słowy macierz jednostkowa podzielona przez N. Wyczyszczenie mianownika daje nam nasze
dwa warunki, więc ta implikacja jest dość szybka i łatwa, bo już ją omówiliśmy.
WEBVTT
Przyjrzyjmy się teraz drugiej implikacji. Tym razem zaczynamy z reprezentacją Choi'ego odwzorowania, o którym
zakładamy, że spełnia dwa wymagania, i naszym celem jest znalezienie reprezentacji Kraussa dla tego odwzorowania, która
spełnia wymaganie, o którym mówiliśmy wcześniej. Ta implikacja jest w pewnym sensie dość mechaniczna: będziemy potrzebować
odrobiny algebry liniowej i głównie sprowadzi się to do manipulowania macierzami i wektorami w dość sprytny
sposób. Zaczyna się od założenia, że reprezentacja Choi'ego jest dodatnio półokreślona, co jest pierwszym z dwóch wymagań, które zakładamy, że są
spełnione. Pojęcie macierzy dodatnio półokreślonej jest fundamentalnie ważne w informacji kwantowej i nie tylko w kontekście macierzy
gęstości – jest absolutnie krytyczne tutaj i nie bylibyśmy w stanie tego zrealizować bez niego. W szczególności założenie,
że J(fi) jest dodatnio półokreślona, pozwala nam wyrazić ją w formie pokazanej na ekranie dla pewnego wyboru
wektorów s_0 do s_ i pewnego wyboru dodatniej liczby całkowitej N. Zaznaczmy wyraźnie, że te nie są
koniecznie wektorami jednostkowymi. Jednym ze sposobów uzyskania takiego wyrażenia jest twierdzenie spektralne dla macierzy dodatnio
półokreślonych, które było omawiane w poprzedniej lekcji. Tutaj nie widzimy żadnych wartości własnych pojawiających się wprost, jak mieliśmy w dekompozycji spektralnej,
ale pamiętaj, że wartości własne macierzy dodatnio półokreślonych są zawsze nieujemnymi liczbami rzeczywistymi i pamiętaj też, że nie wymagamy, żeby te wektory
s_0 do s_ były wektorami jednostkowymi. Możemy więc wziąć pierwiastki kwadratowe z wartości własnych i pomnożyć je do jednostkowych wektorów własnych,
które dostajemy z dekompozycji spektralnej, żeby uzyskać te wektory s_0 do s_. Tak naprawdę nie jest ważne dla tego dowodu, żeby te wektory były ortogonalne;
dostajemy to z dekompozycji spektralnej, ale nie będziemy tu z tego korzystać, i gdybyśmy mieli jakieś inne wyrażenie J(fi) w tej formie, które nie pochodzi z twierdzenia
spektralnego, to byłoby równie dobrze. Teraz rozkładamy każdy z tych wektorów jak pokazano na ekranie,
i to jest tak samo jak zrobilibyśmy to, gdyby te wektory były kwantowymi wektorami stanu pary układów XY i wykonywalibyśmy
pomiar w standardowej bazie na układzie X. Dla jasności nie mierzymy tu niczego; po prostu zapisujemy te wektory w tej formie, co
jest zawsze możliwe. I teraz pojawia się trik: definiujemy macierze Kraussa a_0 do a_ przez „zerwanie" K_A
z frontu tych wektorów s_0 do s_, odwrócenie ich tak, żeby stały się bra_A zamiast ket_A, i wypchnięcie ich na prawą stronę,
jak pokazano w równaniu na ekranie. Jednym ze sposobów myślenia o tym jest to, że zasadniczo „składamy" te wektory żeby tworzyć macierze, tak że gdybyśmy ułożyli kolumny A_K jedną na drugiej,
dostalibyśmy z powrotem s. Więc te macierze mają dokładnie te same elementy, co odpowiadające im wektory, ale po prostu
ułożyliśmy elementy inaczej żeby uzyskać macierze. Ale możemy też myśleć o tych macierzach czysto symbolicznie w kategoriach notacji bezpośredniej,
jak zapisano tutaj. I w tym miejscu pojawia się oczywiste pytanie: dlaczego to powinno działać? Cóż, nie zastanawiajmy się zbytnio
nad tym, dlaczego działa, a po prostu sprawdźmy, że działa. Żeby to zrobić, zdefiniujmy nowe odwzorowanie, czyli odwzorowanie zdefiniowane przez
te macierze, gdzie traktujemy je jako macierze Kraussa. Co możemy teraz zrobić, to obliczyć reprezentację Choi'ego
tego nowego odwzorowania i zobaczymy, że jest równa reprezentacji Choi'ego odwzorowania fi, od którego zaczęliśmy, i
ponieważ reprezentacje Choi'ego są wierne, oznacza to, że te dwa odwzorowania są w istocie równe. Nie będę przechodzić przez algebrę w tym filmie,
możesz sam to sprawdzić, jest to dość mechaniczne i dobra praktyka, a wszystko, czego do tego potrzebujesz, jest tu
na ekranie. Nic jeszcze nie powiedzieliśmy o drugim warunku w dwóch ramkach, ale
okazuje się, że są one równoważne i jednym ze sposobów ustalenia tego jest sprawdzenie równania wyświetlonego tutaj na dole
ekranu. Litera T tutaj nawiasem mówiąc odnosi się do transponowania macierzy, co możesz alternatywnie traktować jako
odwzorowanie liniowe, które zamienia ket_A bra_B na ket_B bra_A, i jest to po prostu coś, co jest potrzebne, żeby formuła działała.
Podsumowując, na pewno potrzeba tu trochę algebry dla tej implikacji, ale jak powiedziałem, jest ona dość mechaniczna –
w zasadzie gimnastyka indeksów, jak niektórzy nazywają tego rodzaju rzeczy. Ale jeśli przez to przejdziesz i dasz mózgowi szansę przetrawienia tego, możesz stwierdzić,
że wychodzisz z lepszym rozumieniem, jak reprezentacje Choi'ego i reprezentacje Kraussa są ze sobą powiązane. Trzecia implikacja pozwala nam
przejść od reprezentacji Kraussa odwzorowania fi, gdzie zwykły warunek jest spełniony, do reprezentacji Steinspringa. Ta
jest dość podobna duchem do poprzedniej implikacji w tym sensie, że jest mechaniczna i można ją traktować i weryfikować w czysto algebraicznych kategoriach.
Idea jest tak naprawdę dość prosta: możemy wziąć nasze macierze Kraussa i uformować część większej macierzy przez ułożenie
ich jednej na drugiej, jak pokazano na ekranie. Gdy będzie wypełniona, to da nam macierz unitarną U dla
reprezentacji Steinspringa. Macierze unitarne muszą być macierzami kwadratowymi, więc będziemy musieli wypełnić tyle pozostałych
kolumn, ile potrzebujemy, ale tak naprawdę nie będzie miało znaczenia, co one są, o ile dostaniemy macierz unitarną.
Jeśli na chwilę odłożymy troskę o to, czy U jest unitarne, i skupimy się tylko na odwzorowaniu liniowym, które jest zdefiniowane przez
reprezentację Steinspringa, którą dostajemy z tej macierzy U, to okaże się, że to odwzorowanie jest równe
oryginalnemu odwzorowaniu fi zdefiniowanemu przez reprezentację Kraussa, od której zaczęliśmy. To jest inna część dowodu, przez którą nie będę przechodzić w tym filmie;
możesz znaleźć szczegóły w pisemnych treściach do tej lekcji, ale możesz też zechcieć poświęcić trochę czasu i samodzielnie przez to przejść. Pamiętaj
tylko, jak zwykle dla tej serii, że używamy konwencji kolejności ket'ów do interpretowania diagramu, więc W i G będą
odpowiadać czynnikom tensorowym po lewej stronie w równaniach. I nawiasem mówiąc, jeśli przez to przejdziesz,
stwierdzisz, że ponieważ mamy ket_0 bra_0 jako czynnik tensorowy po lewej stronie w równaniu,
jedyną częścią U, która ma jakiekolwiek znaczenie, jest ta podana przez macierze Kraussa. Więc o ile wypełnimy
kolumny U w sposób, który czyni je unitarnymi, to jesteśmy w porządku. Oczywiście wymaga to, żeby kolumny uformowane przez a_0 do a_,
gdy ułożymy je jedną na drugiej, były ortonormalne, i tutaj właśnie pojawia się warunek, który stawiamy reprezentacjom Kraussa.
I w istocie jest on precyzyjnie równoważny temu, żeby kolumny były ortonormalne. Odpowiednie matematyczne związki potrzebne do wyciągnięcia tego
wniosku są pokazane tutaj na dole ekranu. Więc zatrzymaj się i sprawdź, jeśli chcesz, lub ponownie
zapoznaj się z pisemnymi treściami, żeby uzyskać więcej szczegółów. Krótko mówiąc, to, co się tu dzieje zarówno w tej implikacji, jak i w
poprzedniej, to to, że opisujemy te same operacje matematyczne na różne, ale równoważne sposoby. Bijące
serce tego wszystkiego zasadniczo to mnożenie macierzy. Czwarta i ostatnia implikacja ustala, że jeśli mamy
reprezentację Steinspringa dla jakiegoś odwzorowania, to to odwzorowanie musi w istocie być prawidłowym kanałem i jak wskazałem
wcześniej, już omówiliśmy tę implikację przy omawianiu reprezentacji Steinspringa. Podsumowując,
a mówiąc nieco inaczej: wprowadzenie zainicjowanego układu roboczego jest prawidłowym kanałem. Wynika to z faktu, że dołączenie ustalonej
macierzy gęstości do danej macierzy gęstości zawsze daje macierz gęstości i jest to odwzorowanie liniowe z powodu dwuliniowości
WEBVTT
iloczynów tensorowych. Operacje unitarne są zawsze prawidłowymi kanałami, jak omawiałem wcześniej w lekcji. Tracowanie układu jest prawidłowym kanałem, bo ślad częściowy
to odwzorowanie liniowe, które zawsze przekształca macierze gęstości w macierze gęstości. I na koniec złożenia
kanałów są zawsze kanałami, co jest dość proste, ale zdecydowanie warte odnotowania samo w sobie. I z tymi
czterema implikacjami, które właśnie omówiliśmy, ustaliliśmy równoważność trzech reprezentacji kanałów wraz z
oryginalną definicją kanału. W szczególności zaczęliśmy od definicji kanału, zobaczyliśmy, jak ta definicja implikuje, że jego reprezentacja Choi'ego
musi spełniać dwa podstawowe warunki, następnie zobaczyliśmy, jak te warunki pozwalają nam znaleźć reprezentację Kraussa, która z kolei
pozwala nam znaleźć reprezentację Steinspringa, i na koniec zobaczyliśmy, że istnienie reprezentacji Steinspringa ujawnia, że mamy w
istocie prawidłowy kanał. Oczywiście są tam szczegóły techniczne i nie jest to koniecznie proste, zwłaszcza
gdy widzisz to po raz pierwszy, ale co ciekawe i godne uwagi to to, że te implikacje są ustawione w sposób, który w istocie czyni
rzeczy tak łatwymi, jak to możliwe. I w matematyce nigdy nie powinieneś się wstydzić brania drogi na skróty.
Na przykład wcale nie jest oczywiste, że każdy kanał ma representację Steinspringa lub representację Kraussa,
ale stosunkowo łatwo wnioskować, że representacja Choi'ego każdego kanału spełnia dwa warunki, które z nią skojarzyliśmy, i to
pozwala nam podążać mniej więcej algebraiczną ścieżką do pozostałych dwóch reprezentacji. Podobnie, ostatnia
implikacja od representacji Steinspringa z powrotem do definicji jest też stosunkowo prosta i
pozwala nam wnioskować, że dostajemy tylko kanały i żadne inne odwzorowania z reprezentacji Choi'ego, zakładając że wymagane
warunki są spełnione. I jak napomknąłem wcześniej, sposób, w jaki uzasadniamy te implikacje, jest wystarczająco mechaniczny, żeby umożliwić nam łatwe konwertowanie
między representacjami i jeśli wrócisz do niektórych przykładów, które omawialiśmy wcześniej w lekcji, stwierdzisz, że faktycznie jest możliwe
konwertowanie między representacjami, czasem dość łatwo i bezpośrednio. I to jest koniec
lekcji, która była w całości o kanałach. Rozmawialiśmy o tym, czym są i przyjrzeliśmy się kilku podstawowym przykładom. Omówiliśmy trzy sposoby, w jakie kanały mogą być
reprezentowane i zagłębiliśmy się w niektóre szczegóły techniczne, które ustanawiają równoważność tych representacji.
Mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie na następnej lekcji, która będzie w całości o pomiarach w ogólnym sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej.
Do widzenia!